[Musique]
bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78 radio
sensations yvelines à l'occasion des
élections municipales premier tour au
programme le 15 mars prochain
focus dans cette émission sur la ville
de plaisir plus de 31 mille habitants
membres de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et au 22
février jour d'enregistrement de ce
débat quatre candidatures sont
officiellement est déclarée sur cette
ville ils vont débattre en plateau elles
vont débattre en plateau de leur
programme le dépôt des listes je le
rappelle la date limite est fixée au 27
février autour de la table joséphine
coleman ce berger maire sortant de
plaisir d'être de liste de plaisir
avance annie joël priou hasseni tête de
liste de tout à faire résolument
écologique solidaire pur plaisir est
djamel niati candidats de la liste à
gauche toute et enfin patrick jean tr
tête de liste de plaisir notre ville
notre avenir bonjour à vous quatre merci
d'avoir répondu favorablement à notre
invitation je rappelle que pour ce débat
les temps de parole s'afficheront
régulièrement et seront que chronométrés
afin de respecter pardon une certaine
équité je précise aussi qu'un tirage au
sort a permis de déterminer l'ordre de
prise de parole pour débuter ce débat et
c'est vous djamel niati qui allait
démarrer vous êtes membre de
l'opposition dans le groupe à gauche
tout l'humain d'abord vous étiez déjà
candidat en 2014 où vous avez récolté un
peu moins de 7 5% des voix pourquoi être
de nouveau candidat sur cette liste à
gauche toute
et pourquoi voter pour vous pour votre
liste alors tout simplement
nous sommes dans la continuité de ce qui
a été notre engagement 2014
donc aujourd'hui nous souhaitons
prolonger notre démarche est le
triptyque est le nôtre aujourd'hui est
de pouvoir apporter du changement pour
notre ville et redonner plaisir
randonnée la ville à nos habitants voilà
au plaisir patrick l'inter vous êtes le
deuxième à prendre la parole dans ce
débat je reprends ma feuille voilà mes
petites notes vous avez été pendant dix
ans adjoint de la ville de plaisir en
charge des finances jusqu'en septembre
2019 vous avez décidé avec d'autres élus
de la majorité de rejoindre l'opposition
dans un groupe ensemble avant son pur
plaisir votre liste elle se nomme
plaisir notre ville notre avenir et est
affiché comme sans étiquette même
question que pour jamal dati pour
pourquoi être candidat oui merci
et bien après une vingtaine d'années
d'expérience d'élu de terrain sur
différentes responsabilités achats
marchés handicap finance et pour porter
des idées qu à plusieurs
nous avons proposé depuis plusieurs
années sans écoute sans être entendus et
donc nous décidons aujourd'hui avec une
liste sans étiquette effectivement de
porter ces idées en avant plus des coûts
de plus de proximité plus
d'environnements plus de démocratie
participative plus effectivement de
mobilité on ne développera tout à
l'heure c'est une liste avant tout les
iroise
c'est une liste de citoyens les co
responsables qui veut porter des valeurs
démocrates humanistes des valeurs
portées vers l'autre pour l'autre pour
les plaisirs ouah c'est pour ça que nous
avons appelé notre liste effectivement
plaisir notre ville notre avenir nous
sommes tous plaisir à nous vivons et
nous aimons et nous habitons notre ville
a vendu joséphine coleman ce berger
maire de plaisir depuis 2012 vous étiez
auparavant adjointe ou conseil municipal
et vous avez succédé à jouer la réunio
démissionnaire vous êtes candidate pour
un troisième mandat plaisir avancé
soutenue par le rassemblement heavy noah
qui regroupe notamment les fédérations
yvelinoise des républicains du dei de
génération terrain et de libre et votre
candidature est aussi soutenu par la
république en marche pourquoi être de
nouveau candidate pour pour ce troisième
mandat je voudrais rectifier c'est pas
mon troisième mandat
le deuxième et puis vous dire que eh
bien justement depuis témoin de ce
mandat complet c'est ça depuis 2001 la
ville de plaisir a fortement changé
énormément dans beaucoup de domaines
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
ville qui est dans une dynamique
économique on n'a même pas 5% 6% de
chômage
et puis on a un développement culturel
un développement sportif on a une écoute
très forte auprès de la population avec
un accompagnement qui va de la petite
enfance jusqu'au maintien à domicile
c'est à dire qu'on est une ville qui est
dans un bel équilibre et en plus tout
cela dans une ville qu'on appelle ville
à la campagne avec nos 54 % et bien de
ruralité que non seulement nous
maintenons mais nous souhaitons
développer avec avec un partage avec la
population que nous avons déjà commencé
depuis pas mal d'années puisque ne
serait ce que sur les six années nous
avons pu faire plus de 300 rencontres de
réunions de quartier avec l'ensemble de
la population est aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on est dans une véritable ouverture
par rapport à ce que les plaisirs wa
attendait attendent encore bien sûr
puisqu'on est dans ce développement d'
écoute très participative également et
puis dans la continuité de ce que nous
avons faits dont nous n'avons vraiment
pas à rougir je crois annie jouer le
trio hasseni vous terminer ce premier
tour de table conseillère municipale
d'opposition dans le groupe à eux pp à
venir votre liste où tafer pur plaisir
est également sans étiquette c'est une
liste sans étiquette mais a le soutien
du parti socialiste et d'europe écologie
les verts pourquoi être candidate à
plaisir et bien
d'abord depuis 22 ans j'habite plaisir
j'ai été rapidement dans l'engagement à
plaisir pour cette ville et présidents
d'associations de parents d'élèves
présidentes d'associations culturelles
de théâtre est effectivement comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure
élue conseillère municipale d'opposition
depuis 2014
et depuis 2018 avec ma colistière
isabelle halsou pays
nous avons rencontré les plaisirs oit
sur le terrain et nous avons
effectivement fait un constat qu' il y
avait des dysfonctionnements qu'il y
avait un manque d coûte un manque
d'attention même de reconnaissance et
nous avons défendu avec nos outils de
membres de l'opposition
nous avons défendu et bien le comité
plus de bus avec l'arrivée du nouveau
réseau de bus de saint quentin nous
étions sur le terrain avec eux nous
avons défendu un plan de ville pour les
pistes cyclables qui n'a pas été écoutée
et entendue
nous avons défendu également cette perte
malheureuse des éducateurs spécialisés
nous avons défendu par la perte mais le
fait que justement qu'ils soient perdus
et qui soit effacée du paysage social de
plaisir
donc voilà donc toutes ces raisons font
que eh bien on se présente avant tout à
faire effectivement nous sommes des
tafurs il ya beaucoup de travail à faire
voilà pour l'introduction annie jouer le
trio a signé vous êtes à une minute
trente de temps de parole patrick jean
terre et je défile coleman ce verger
autour d une minute
djamel niati à 22 secondes on aura
l'occasion de rééquilibrer sa dans un
instant pour
pour suivre ce débat avant de poursuivre
ce débat ce sujet qui résume les
principaux enjeux pour la commune de
plaisir dans cette campagne des
municipales 2020 et le point est fait
avec michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
dandois c'est une commune ouverte sur la
plaine de versailles un territoire
partagé entre la campagne et la ville
plaisir et ses trente et un mille
habitants ont rejoint la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2016 ce
territoire essaie de trouver un
équilibre entre urbanisation et zones
naturelles le pôle commercial va
s'agrandir cette année avec l'ouverture
d'open sky et des emplois pour le
plaisir oies à la clé d'urbanisation
c'est la réhabilitation du centre bourg
et la rénovation du quartier du vélib ou
un investissement de 65 millions d'euros
un projet déjà engagé que devra
poursuivre le prochain maire de la ville
avec une prise en compte plus globale de
ce quartier touché par la délinquance
les questions sociales et l'emploi des
aménagements environnementaux sont aussi
prévues dans ce futur écoquartier
l'environnement est aussi une
préoccupation plaisir compte une forêt
plusieurs parcs naturels la question des
transports et de la circulation sera
posée notamment après l'aménagement de
la rd 30 et de la passerelle plaisir et
l'encours le phénomène de désert médical
plane au dessus de plaisir une ville
classée en zone d'action complémentaire
par l' agence régionale de santé
ils sont quatre médecins pour 10000
habitants 2017 selon les derniers
chiffres de l'ue rps il y avait quatorze
médecins généralistes ils sont âgés de
50 ans en moyenne
mais des enjeux que nous allons
développer un peu plus au cours de ce
débat à commencer par celui de
l'environnement de la transition
écologique
on peut le dire assez le thème fort de
cette campagne des élections municipales
plaisir ça a été dit dans le sujet une
ville à la campagne où il faut sans
cesse trouver équilibre entre
urbanisation et zone naturelle je
rappelle aussi qu'il ya une forêt à
plaisir des enjeux aussi qui concerne
sur cette transition écologique les
questions de circulation on parlait au
cours de nos éditions sur tv 78 du
réaménagement de la rd 30 1 er et
aménagements récents de la rd 30 on va
faire un premier tour de table pour
détailler vos mesures je vous le
donnerai la parole si vous souhaitez
répondre et apporter des précisions sur
ce qui a été dit je vais vous donner
d'abord vous la parole à vous de jamais
niati vous êtes à 22 secondes de temps
de parole pour vous l'écologie doit être
au centre de toutes les réflexions à
avoir à plaisir santé est quelque chose
d'antinomique dents
dans les propos vous alliez vous saviez
soulever ces écologie et développement
durable
moi je pense que cette antinomie qui par
nature eux
le développement exponentiel et donc la
course à la consommation constitue le
principe de la principale menace pour
l'écologie donc rien que cela déjà me
perturbe donc sur le principe le
raisonnement écologique c'est sûr sur le
principe de certains qui met ça
aujourd'hui en politique dans tout les
dents à toutes les sauces c'est vraiment
la problématique de 2,2 de production et
de surproduction donc l'écologiste c'est
pas ça se limite pas aux petits gestes
du quotidien ce serait trop gentil c'est
facile de faire passer le consommateur
pour un dangereux
un dangereux pollueurs donc déjà une
fois qu'on a dit ça c'est assez c'est
assez
ça permet de poser un peu le débat et a
hérité de 2,2 des tergiversions moyens
point qui me surprend quand même c'est
que on a aujourd'hui une envie
d'écologie tous
mais bon moi sur plaisir j'ai un vrai
souci c'est le tente de la
surconsommation donc parler d'écologie
alors qu'on construit des centres
commerciaux à tout va moi ça me surprend
donc vous me parliez de ça oui
l'écologie ça passerait déjà parus tout
ce qui est véritablement construction
redistribution et qu'on va dire
animations dans les quartiers peut-être
mais surtout distribution dans les
quartiers le fait de pouvoir accéder
dans les quartiers donc ça veut dire
revoir une circulation différentes
c'est le comment es tu avec le fic lable
pas forcément les pistes aux cycles déjà
le fait d'avoir déjà un transport qui
soient à la portée de tous
tout le monde n'a pas de voiture un
plaisir alors que tout est fait pour les
voitures donc les pistes cyclables c'est
un moyen de 2 et placé mais on peut déjà
faire en sorte de faire en sorte que les
piétons puissent déjà circulé c'est déjà
un premier pas dire après on peut mettre
tout ce que l'on veut des bornes
électriques des points de recharge pour
les vélos moi j'ai pas de jets pas de
souci tout ça c'est bien
on n'est pas dans la conception faut
parler d'éco conception géant départ
c'est déjà le premier souci
après on parlait d'écologie l'écologie
aujourd'hui ça c'est kelly lequel ce cas
les adhémar sur l'écologie sur les
bâtiments publics déjà et pas de
récupération d'énergie de récupération
d'eau voilà rien que ça ccc le berre bas
donc dont je parlais d'éco-conception
s'est pas demandé aux plaisirs roi de
faire attention à bien jeter dans la
poubelle bleue les des déchets en qui
qui sont récupérés voilà le défi de la
canne de berger deux des quatre axes de
votre programme aborde la question de
l'environnement lax ville nature et l'ex
ville responsable vous souhaitez
notamment préserver et développer les
espaces verts développer l'e mobilité
propre et douce et aussi aller vers le
zéro carbone comment comptez-vous y
parvenir que le déjà on peut peut-être
rappeler des choses qui ont été faites
parce que s'y est pas anodin
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau du chauffage
urbain avec le résop et les 6km de raju
qui avait été fait sur la ville ça me
semble important de le rappeler au
niveau également des compositeurs et des
récupérateurs d'eau il y en a eu des
milliers de distribuer sur la
collectivité ça peut paraître
anecdotique mais ça me semble plutôt
important au niveau ici des transports
c'est quelque chose vous évoquez les
pistes cyclables ans vient de terminer
justement tout un cadrage d'études sur
les pistes cyclables niveau de la ville
parce que je rejoins monsieur n'y a t'il
bien évidemment c'est pas un temple de
la voiture qu'il faut développer
c'est bien sûr un développement au
niveau des pistes cyclables
aujourd'hui on sait pertinemment que
nous avons plus de 25 kilomètres à faire
sur la ville de plaisir mais qui ce qui
ce qui sont également pour le
département pour la voix les voies
d'intérêt communautaire et la ville y'a
pas uniquement la ville qui doit prendre
ça en charge ya quand même quatre
millions d'euros d'investissement c'est
un vrai un investissement et puis aussi
vous parler de dutemple commercial le
temple commercial est aussi un endroit
avec lesquels nous travaillons
aujourd'hui pour justement développer
toutes les zones piétonnes dans ce dans
cet espace là qui est un endroit bien
sûr de développement économique
indispensable puisque nous sommes
aujourd'hui un centre régional il faut
pas se mentir
mais c'est aussi un endroit qui en
réflexion aujourd'hui par rapport à tout
ça et puis les zones de covoiturage les
bornes électriques bien sûr ça n'apporte
pas forcément je dirais la possibilité
de marcher davantage mais en tout cas
c'est aussi un apport tout ce qui est
développement de du respect de la nature
au niveau de tout ce qui est de carbone
l'éco-quartier du vally bout ce n'est
pas anodin je veux dire aujourd'hui les
65 millions d'euros qui ont été évoqués
dans le reportage fait partie aussi de
cette démarche très importante que nous
avons sur la ville de plaisir de faire
de ce quartier non seulement un
développement pour la population une
amélioration je dirais de l'habitat du
centre commercial en fait tout ce qui
est va être développée avec ses 65
millions d'euros
mais un écoquartier et permettez-moi de
juste rajouté puisque je sais que je
prends un peu trop de problèmes luxe
voilà le centre bourg est aussi un
endroit qui n'est pas fait uniquement
pour faire un développement patrimonial
et rien que ça c'est aussi parce que il
va y avoir 20 hectares qui vont se
libérer au centre par le déménagement de
charcot et nous devons avoir une
élections justement pour toutes ces axes
aulas qui sont des axes prioritaires de
leur environnement bien sûr on aura
l'occasion de reparler du valais bout
puisque c'est aussi un sujet qui à
cheval sur le prochain thème qui est sur
l'urbanisation on en parlera dans un
instant patrick jouin terre vous fixé au
6 1 l'objectif du zéro carbone d'ici
2050 même si dans votre programme vous
vous engagez à réduire de 20% les
émissions au cours du prochain mandat
ceux-ci favoriser l'économie verte a
créé 20 km de pistes cyclables à plaisir
parmi vos propositions
oui absolument l'écologie est au centre
au coeur de nos préoccupations et des
actions que nous proposons c'est aussi
au coeur des différentes sensibilités
qui sont dans notre liste et qui font
que nous souhaitons effectivement
opérationnaliser un petit peu toutes les
idées pour lesquelles nous nous sommes
battus depuis un certain nombre d'années
l'une d'elles s'est effectivement les
mobilités douces ou les mobilités
propres nous n'avons pas été entendus
nous avons demandé depuis plusieurs
années de démarrer les pistes cyclables
aujourd'hui nous sommes au point
quasiment zéro donc nous nous engageons
effectivement à ce que plus de 20
kilomètres de pistes cyclables soient
réalisées sur l'ensemble du mandat nous
nous sommes battus aussi sur le dossier
des bus parce que les transports en
commun c'est une manière aussi de ne pas
m'être que de la voiture au coeur de la
ville nous reprendrons ce dossier des
bus face à la région ile de france s'il
le faut et nous mettrons des navettes
interquartiers nous avons proposé il y a
déjà quelques temps un partenariat avec
une industrie pour mettre en place des
navettes interquartiers propres nous les
mettrons en place parce que nous sommes
toujours avec le même dossier et nous
souhaitons le conduire nous avons un
autre dossier qui était là d'ailleurs
lors de notre réunion publique avec un
partenaire une start up qui est prêt à
installer un certain nombre de bornes de
recharge électrique des kiosques de
service complètement auto financé pour
la vie zéro euro nous allons nous
engager sur du maraîchage de proximité
maraîchage urbain sur des circuits
courts à la fois pour valoriser notre
marché et apporter une diversification
concerne
alimentation bio mais également pour nos
cantines en rajoutant et je profite de
l'occasion pour transformer notre
politique d'achat marché en politique
éco-responsable en rajoutant notamment
l'impact carbone comme l'un des critères
de notre stratégie d'achat et enfin nous
allons oeuvrer aussi surtout la kz2
sensibilisation au travers d'actions
vis-à-vis des écoles par exemple la
fresque du climat et autres un certain
nombre d'actions avec les associations
et comme nous allons beaucoup travailler
sur la démocratie participative avec un
conseil des jeunes et des conseils de
quartier nous ferons des appels à
projets auprès des citoyens avec des
budgets doté et notamment sur l'écologie
et le mieux vivre ensemble
voilà quelques lignes je dirais d'action
que nous souhaitons conduire à noël
prioux à ce niveau propositions sur
cette thématique vous souhaiter
réfléchir à des solutions qui se
passerait de la voiture remettre des
voies vertes faciliter les accès en
forêt aussi développer les circuits
courts notamment mettre en place des
potagers dans les écoles c'est parmi vos
propositions sont parmi vos propositions
oui c'est bien oui oui c'est tout à fait
ça écoutez effectivement on pourrait
presque dire quasiment dire autour de
cette table nous sommes pratiquement
tous d'accord qu est-ce que finalement
nous sommes d'accord sur l'écologie
effectivement monsieur niati l'écologie
des petits gestes c'est dépassé on n'est
plus du tout dans cette situation là
nous voulons tous de l'écologie pour les
vies toutes les listes soient
écologiques
donc ce qu'il y a de différent peut-être
avec peut-être d'ailleurs sûrement avec
notre liste c'est que c'est une écologie
politique
nous sommes aussi la liste qui est la
seule soutenu par un label quand même
historique
europe ecologie les verts vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure c'est c'est une
légitimité aussi de faire confiance à
une tête de liste qui est sans étiquette
c'est déjà quand même
atout important quelque chose de très
important d'autre part dans notre façon
d'aborder le problème que ce soit pour
l'écologie vive la solidarité se sont
vraiment nous deux pieds
en terre qu'on passe finalement toutes
les décisions les appels d'offres
notamment par ses deux axes la valeur de
la solidarité alors oui mais parce qu'on
ne veut pas les dissocier
et je concernant par exemple pour des
exemples parce que j'en ai beaucoup en
tête mais vous les avez déjà
pratiquement aussi de données et sur les
voies douces voie verte pistes cyclables
mais c'est pas en donnant non plus un
nombre de kilomètres qu'on arrive à
vraiment comprendre ce que ça veut dire
il faut aussi d'abord mettre tout à plat
quand on a si on était nu quand on
arrive et qu'on est élu il faut savoir
de quoi on parle donc s'est réajusté et
les plaisirs auront des choses à dire
pour ça ils ont des idées ils ont des
projets et j'en parlais tout à l'heure
il y avait un plan de pistes cyclables
qui avait été fait qui a été refusé et
revenir aussi notamment dans les
cantines on a une obligation lui d'avoir
20 % de produits bio
or on aurait pu commencer plus tôt et on
n'en serait peut-être on demande en tout
cas plus de bio aujourd'hui et est
notamment introduire aussi enfin faire
en sorte qu'ils aient moins de produits
carnés
tout cela va dans le même dans le même
système la même situation n'aurait
bientôt à 4 minutes d'origine parole est
très bien voilà bah si brou je laisse
l'allemagne at il que vous avez environ
une minute de retard sur les autres
candidats si vous voulez peut-être
ajouter quelque chose avant qu'on parle
de l'urbanisation qui a un thème lié
aussi à celui de l'écologie
aujourd'hui quand on parle d'écologie on
nie tout tout tout le monde et
écologiste aujourd'hui c'est assez
marrant on parlait d' approche politique
oui moi j'affiche clairement mon
appartenance politique à un mouvement de
gauche qui se déclare et c'est avec les
étiquettes qui vont avec sans faire
semblant donc nous et les filles
génération le pg le parti communiste
nous soutiennent même si moi je n'ai pas
de je ne suis encarté nulle part mais
sur le principe les valeurs de gauche
sont par nature porteuse de valeurs
écologiques je suis nourri contre la
surproduction on est contre toute cette
toute cette démarche d'externalisation
de services publics
ce qu'on parlait madame noël prioux sni
parler de la cantine et compagnie la
cantine y avait une cantine on va dire
restaurant on va dire municipal qui
permettait de faire les repas à la
cantine et cantines scolaires on va dire
qui a été externalisé les repas viennent
de rouen tous les jours voilà après
c'est je veux dire c'est comparer un
pris un coup tout simplement donc nous
on est plutôt dans une logique de coût
que de prix c'est à dire que la logique
de faire payer cher des repas qui sont
pas forcément bio comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure à 20% ce qui est quand
même le minimum minimorum mais c'est
quand même surprenant c'est que aux
alentours il ya des maraîchers mais
quand même dans une danse une région
maraîchères et quand même moyen de faire
manger nos enfants et nos anciens parce
que ce sera aussi l'objectif de faire
une cantine beaucoup plus ouverte à des
repas bonus vert pour des gens comptent
pas les moyens et sur le fond c'est
d'avoir véritablement que d'utiliser les
produits de proximité chez les circuits
courts c'est pas nouveau mais on est là
quand la ville à la campagne ou la
campagne à la ville je crois
qu'aujourd'hui est plutôt la ville à la
campagne
tu te réaction même calomnieuse
simplement pour dire que tout ce que
j'entends ne peut être que positif bien
sûr puisque tout ce qui a été évoqué
j'ai l'impression que nous faisons déjà
mais vous dire que par exemple pour les
cantines oui peut-être un peu tard
le bio mais en tout cas c'est fait et ce
qui est très important aussi c'est de
savoir que aujourd'hui dans tout ce qui
est participatif et bien les tables de
tri qui ont été installés aussi dans les
cantines ce n'est pas anodin puisque
vous savez que les déchets fait aussi
partie de cette réflexion par rapport à
la ville est aujourd'hui on est à moins
de 48 % de déchets de ce qu'on avait
précédemment et de pertes dans les
cantines juste juste un mot pour dire
que on est on est d'accord je dirais
dans l'ensemble puisque ce sont des
attentes des habitants et que ce que
vous avez pu vous entendre nous l'avons
entendu également puisque nous avons
fait énormément de réunion et on sait
que aujourd'hui cet accompagnement à ce
que vous évoquiez sur tous tous ces
sujets là sont des sujets sur lesquels
on ne peut être que d'accord et nous on
a déjà beaucoup planché de choses et je
le sais puisque les pistes cyclables je
ne sais pas de quoi vous parlez par
rapport au refus mais en tout cas sur ce
que nous sommes en train de mettre en
place c'est quelque chose qui est très
très concret et qui a véritablement
démarré aujourd'hui
coup d'oeil sur les temps de parole je
définis coleman verger vous êtes à
quatre minutes et 44 secondes jamais
niati 3 minutes 55 patrick jouin terre
trois minutes 26 annie à joël prio
hasseni 3 minutes et 55 secondes on
passe à la deuxième thématique de ce
débat qui élit un forcément c'est celle
de l'urbanisation
on parlait du centre bourg il y aussi ce
projet phare qu'est la rénovation du
quartier du val hibou qui prévoit des
réhabilitations mais aussi des
destructions et construction de
logements 65 millions d'euros pour ce
quartier du val hibou dont le premier
pas vers la labellisation éco quartier a
été franchie avec un vote au conseil
municipal
rappelons également ça a été évoqué que
sur cette commune de plaisir va ouvrir
prochainement un nouveau centre
commercial celui d'open sky qui ouvrira
donc tout prochainement à plaisir avec
une trentaine de boutiques et un cinéma
patrick j'enterre vos propositions sur
l'urbanisation
le projet du malibu a continué peut-être
c'est l'un des projets à suivre déjà
prendre je propose de prendre un petit
peu de recul ou deux auteurs
l'urbanisation ça se pense globalement
avec des stationnements avec de la
circulation avec un bien vivre dans la
ville la ville dans la nature et aussi
la nature dans la vie
ne nous étonnons aujourd'hui d'un
certain nombre de constats qui ne sont
pas les nôtres
le vélib ou un écoquartier non valley
bout c'est encore un projet de bétonnage
pour lequel les habitants n'ont pas été
entendus oui ils ont été réunis mais pas
entendus ils ont demandé un certain
nombre d'améliorations sur les parties
sur les places de stationnement sur les
parcs et jardins
à la place on leur propose d'abattre des
tours et de mettre dehors
56 familles pour lesquelles une solution
de relogement n'est pas trouvée on veut
derrière le silo reconstruire un centre
commercial au lieu de mettre des jeux
des parcs et jardins est donc un poumon
vert au coeur de la ville le silo qui a
été démolie et plus précises absolument
ce sur quoi nous nous inscrivons
effectivement en faut et nous allons
proposer une autre approche
c'est la même chose pour open sky avec
des quartiers qui aujourd'hui craignent
des problèmes d'insécurité à l'aqueduc à
la brétèche aller qui demain vont être
envahi de milliers de voitures
supplémentaires de milliers de visiteurs
supplémentaires avec des problématiques
de circulation de stationnement de
sécurité je le répète donc
l'urbanisation ça doit se réfléchir
globalement et nous allons oeuvrer
effectivement pour une transition à la
fois écologiques énergétiques y compris
dans la manière d'aborder l'urbanisation
avec plus de participatif jeu le site
est tout à l'heure au travers des
conseils de quartier au travers d'un
conseil des jeunes au travers de
davantage effectivement 2d coûte de
concertation de construction ensemble
pour réaliser plus de poumon vert au
sein de la ville pour réaliser une vraie
transition énergétique avec une
certification iso 50001 notamment sur
les bâtiments de la ville pour baisser
notre impact carbone pour oeuvrer
ensemble vers l'avenir et construire une
ville effectivement plus verte plus
agréable à vivre est plus solidaire on
va vous laisser répondre dans un instant
joséphine colmate berger je me tourne
vers vous d'abord annie joël priaulx
hasseni une position vous c'est aussi
lutter ça fait partie de vos
propositions lutter contre le bétonnage
l'immobilier oui je reprends vos propos
oui vous
alors je précise quand même l'abus de
bétonnage c'est effectivement il faut
quand même construire mais il faut pas
construire n'importe comment n'importe
quoi je n'ai pas dit que c'était
n'importe quoi n'importe comment ou
simplement faire attention d'abord
prévenu aussi je rejoins monsieur j'ai
un terme et je pense que tout le monde
est d'accord autour de cette table
peut-être est d'accord mais en action ne
le font pas c'est à dire que
effectivement les idées des plaisirs war
la parole de plaisir où le discours du
plaisir aux as doit être prise en compte
et pas une fois que ces actes et une
fois qu'on a déjà lancé un projet c'est
en amont et ça c'est effectivement une
méthode complètement nouvelle nous
sommes en suis désolé on parle de
l'urbanisation mais ça englobe tout nous
sommes face les personnes qui sont
autour de cette table sont dans d une
politique plus traditionnel de
reproduction de discours basé sur un
budget or nous nous sommes plutôt dans
une politique de de moyens et de besoins
au regard d'abord les besoins des
plaisirs à et ensuite on y adapte les
moyens et effectivement le budget est la
même le même par dont l'enveloppé la
même pour revenir à l'urbanisation
eh bien oui c'est vrai que effectivement
faire attention à pas trop de bétonnage
en tout cas quand on se promène
quand on se promène quand on peut parce
que moi je suis souvent à pied j'ai
quand même du mal à traverser certains
ronds-points et certaines rues lier les
conducteurs d'automobiles sont toujours
surpris de me voir et de voir un piéton
bref quand on est dans ce canton vous
croiser les plaisirs oit il y avait
effectivement un sentiment de trop de
bétonnage c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
le sentiment donc le ressenti des pays
est aussi très important s'il avait été
informé avant son était peut-être
différent et cet équilibre rural urbain
qui fait la caractéristique de notre
ville il est mise à mal
donc effectivement si on continue des
prolongements comme ça de construction
on aura
du mal à comprendre l'équilibré rural et
concernant les projets s'il me reste un
petit peu de temps j'arrive à 6 minutes
vous aurez peut-être moins de temps et
bien après pour vous exprimer sur
d'autres se reprendre à la fin juste on
va me laisser répondre joséphine coleman
berger je précise juste que parmi vos
propositions il ya aussi le souhait de
lutter contre l'étalement urbain et de
remettre notamment la nature au coeur
des quartiers bien sûr il faut il faut
aussi quand même savoir quelque chose
l'organisation elle est aussi géré par
des règles et par des lois et par
intérêt lui et aujourd'hui quand vous
avez des privés qui vendent à des
promoteurs il est vrai que c'est très
compliqué derrière quand ça correspond
je dirais aux règles du pays et lui
d'empêcher certaines choses malgré tout
ce que nous avons pu mettre en place sur
plaisir ce sont des bâtiments qui
aujourd'hui à 54% sont achetés par des
plaisirs wa donc à une vraie demande est
une vraie attente
et puis aussi ce qui est important de
dire c'est que aujourd'hui à plaisir on
a toujours 31700 habitants c'est à dire
que cette bétonisation elle ne développe
pas à outrance le nombre d'habitants au
à la crainte de certaines personnes le
budget fait bien évidemment partie des
réflexions d'une ville on ne peut pas
travailler sur une ville et développer
des choses sans être dans une règle
budgétaire et puis aussi le mot
bétonnage me semble un peu exagéré on
n'est pas dans un bétonnage dirais non
concertée chaque fois qu'il ya des
projets on est en lien ayant co
construction avec les habitants sur des
sujets très précis puisque nous le
faisons en permanence depuis des années
et dire que nous n'écoutons pas les
plaisirs roi serait un petit peu fort et
je n'accepte pas pour ce qui est du
value lever debout qu'on a mis des
années à aller chercher 65 millions
d'euros
ce quartier était complètement je dirais
à l'abandon non seulement on a réussi à
avoir la réhabilitation des trois
tranches
la réhabilitation des intérieurs de
logements puisque c'est ce qui était
reproché aux bailleurs mais aujourd'hui
avec ses 65 millions sur les huit ans à
venir il va pas y avoir du bétonnage
comme vous dites monsieur jean terre
c'est fou y'avait y avoir un garage
solidaire il va y avoir un seul fait
nouveau une maison associative
il va y avoir la pmi le ccs le sas
un centre commercial certes tout neuf
qui va être mis en place sous peut-être
quelques bâtiments dans lesquels il va y
avoir cette mixité sociale attendue
puisque aujourd'hui au dans le cadre du
vally brut ya des gens qui veulent aller
à l'accession à la propriété
j'étais hier soir et je termine dans une
réunion avec une quarantaine de femmes
du quartier du val et beau qui m'ont
effectivement dit qu'elle aimerait bien
pouvoir avoir une acquisition et ne pas
quitter le quartier
donc tout ce qui est prévu dans le
quartier du mahdi bout c'est aussi les
espaces verts les jeux la
résidentialisation pour les par qui
jeudi on est dans une vision globale en
lien direct avec les habitants et en co
construction avec patrick jane eyre je
vais vous donner à porte dans un instant
si vous la portez un mot de réponses
justes jamais négatif si vous êtes à 4
minutes en remuant de temps de parole
vous écouter sur le le thème de
l'urbanisation
alors aujourd'hui j'entends les gens
temps j'entends 65 millions d'euros
effectivement c'est l'anru à financer
madame le maire effectivement en grande
partie non contrepartie le département
je suis bien voyez excusez moi c'est
surtout bon plaisir
donc c'est c'était le sous-entendu donc
aller se battre pour l'estrie bruits des
subventions au niveau national
départemental
effectivement vous pouvez vu vos mandats
vos différents mandats donc je vous
laisse le faire une fête très bien ceci
étant quand on parle de 65 millions
c'est 65 millions sur lequel les
plaisirs - n'ont rien eu à dire les
plaisirs web du valley où ça a été ça
l'aurait été imposées donc en termes de
concertation dames le maire vous arrivez
avec vos projets vous l'heureux vous
leur imposez il fait de l'information
c'est pas ça la coopération avec
l'épisode les gens au moins c'est dit
les gens ou sans s'aligner et c'est pas
péjoratif mais nous ne nous en avons
assez en tant que citoyen de se voir
imposer des choses il est quand même
temps maintenant en 2020 de faire
participer les gens au processus de
décision et de l'élaboration de projets
donc déjà la première des choses en
terme d'urbanisme
je pense que la première des choses
c'est de demander aux gens ce qu'ils en
pensent et quand on parle d'organisation
effectivement il ya le pendant
l'écologie vous avez tout à fait raison
dans ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
moi j'ai un exemple on parlait de 20
hectares qui vont se libérer sur le
l'ancien hôpital charcot pourquoi pensez
projets de construction pour qu'on fera
un parc pour contrer pas un parc c'est
une personne a posé la question
je vais terminer même le même je ne vous
ai pas interrompu donc sur le principe
pourquoi ne pas faire un parc personnel
à bord on est en train d'éluder le sujet
c'est encore une fois c'est décidé en
catimini dans un coin et ça va être
amenée au conseil municipal et ça va
être votée d'une seule main parce que
parce que c'est comme ça c'est le mode
de fonctionnement
donc nous sur notre mode de
fonctionnement de l'urbanité sur tout le
reste c'est de la concertation et de la
co construction s'est pas de
l'imposition voilà très rapidement juste
sur ce sujet du parc ces 20 hectares
n'appartiennent pas la ville ils
appartiennent à l'hôpital de plaisir au
centre hospitalier non je conseille
vient du nom du conseil de surveillance
et il est clair que ces 20 hectares
aujourd'hui sont dans une réflexion au
niveau du centre bourg et il est clair
que effectivement si l'hôpital va vendre
il vend pas vendre pour faire un parc
donc il est important que nous soyons
dans ce travail
aujourd'hui nous avons terminé le
diagnostic est aujourd'hui nous
commençons le travail et à la dernière
réunion mais cela dit il y avait 250
personnes qui étaient là et qui ont
participé aux grands axes justement de
cet espace qui doit devenir un espace
tout à fait en développement sur cinq
restait et en respect de ce qu'attendent
les plaisirs moi je voulais scali
troisièmes coûte 250 habitants sur 32 me
voilà je vous laisse ajouté peut-être un
mot encore avant de passer sur cette
prochaine thématique la prochaine
thématique qui sera dédiée à la santé
sur le thème de l'urbanisation patridge
inter puis trois points tout d'abord
effectivement la dernière réunion qui a
eu lieu il ya eu énormément de
mécontentement les questions qui étaient
posées étaient largement orienté il
eu un certain nombre de personnes dans
la salle qui se sont élevés contre la
manière de poser les questions qu'ils
voulaient davantage de parcs d'abord
davantage de jardin davantage de poumon
vert on leur répétait oui mais dans ce
cas là il va falloir densifier et
construire plus haut donc il y avait une
espèce d'incompréhension entre la proche
qui était proposé ce que voulait
réellement les personnes dans la salle
il faut en tenir compte y compris pour
l'avenir qui que ce soit qui viendra aux
commandes demain il faut faire attention
à bien poser le débat à plat et bien
écoutez ou du moins écouter et entendre
aussi je voudrais rebondir sur deux
choses concernant l'urbanisation la
première revenir sur le vanni bout
aujourd'hui on a fait beaucoup dans le
paraître
on n'est pas allé sur le fond du
problème on a fait des fresques oui mais
on n'a pas résolu les problèmes en bas
des fresques sur les parkings sur les
parcs et jardins sur le millefeuille qui
a été détruit qui n'a toujours pas été
reconstruit c'est une salle qui
comportait des activités pour les ados
pour les familles pour l'insertion à
l'emploi etc
nous nous engageons à rebâtir cela est
aussi à lutter contre l'insalubrité il
ya beaucoup d'appartements qui sont
encore insalubres aujourd'hui et qui met
qui porte atteinte à la dignité des
familles alors que l'extérieur et refait
donc j'attire l'attention là dessus et
la dernière chose sur laquelle je
voudrais intervenir
c'est à propos d' open sky open sky a eu
un chantier de plusieurs années qui a
porté atteinte à la place du commerce et
aux rues adjacentes
il a toujours été dit nous ne sommes
toujours battus pour cela pour que le
promoteur prennent en charge la
réfection de la place du commerce et la
rue dernièrement il a été voté que la
mairie allait payer un million huit avec
une part de subventions donc néanmoins
avec nos impôts pour réhabiliter cette
place du commerce et la rue nous nous
élevons contre cette mesure non pas pour
ne pas refaire la place du commerce mais
pour repenser les choses autrement il
surtout faire en sorte qu'un promoteur
assume ses responsabilités quand
effectivement il porte atteinte à nos
rues et à nos places voilà un ami joël
prix ou hasseni sur cette thématique de
l'urbanisation avant qu'on passe à un
autre sujet si vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter
oui alors
pour revenir sur l'écoquartier j'avais
j'étais intervenu lors du dernier
conseil municipal
effectivement et j'avais également parlé
des fresques et de ce décalage entre
cette ses ornements de façade et ce qui
se passe c'est très bien de l'avoir dit
en bas c'est à dire au niveau des
parkings
parce qu'encore une fois ce sont les les
personnes qui habitent le vélib ou
qu'ils nous le disent moi je n'invente
rien même si j'habite de vous coûter
donc il ya un décalage entre ces projets
et les attentes véritable de déplaisir
oies et concernant effectivement le
terrain charcot ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut vraiment regarder de près
c'est une réflexion qui fait partie du
centre bourg c'est un poumon vert je
reprends votre expression c'est un
poumon très important dans la ville au
centre ville
donc nous nous aurions l'idée mais ça
fait partie d'une réflexion d'y
installer des résidences pour les
étudiants parce que nous avons
université qui est tout près tout proche
parent dont deux de plaisir et nous
n'avons pas de logement qui peuvent
accueillir justement ces étudiants et
des jeunes couples également débat de la
ville de plaisir en vue de ces élections
municipales vous nous suivez sur tv 78
également sur radio sensations yvelines
troisième thématique
à présent c'est la désertification
médicale plaisir est classé par l'
agence régionale de santé en zone
d'action complémentaire 14 médecins
médecin pardon généralistes dont la
plupart sont proches de la retraite sont
en sont à plaisir lors comment éviter
une situation de désertification
comment ré attirer aussi sur cette ville
de plaisir de jeunes médecins vos
propositions regarde juste les temps de
parole et on aperçoit donc que jamel
niati est un peu en retard 5e minute 35
sur le temps de parole par rapport aux
autres candidats dont je vais vous
écoutez d'abord sur sur cette thématique
de la désertification médicale comment
on fait face à cette thématique
c'est le problème l approche est simple
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes en train
de poser une question ils encore on fait
face comment on a oublié de planifier la
chose le problème il est là c'est pas on
sait pas aujourd'hui on arrive devant le
fait accompli
ça n'a pas été ça a été très sympa ça
n'a pas été planifié en temps et en
heure vous êtes santa fe
là monsieur depuis 2001 fouillez vos
amis d'ailleurs c'est quand même
étonnant de se rendre compte que la
gestion notamment des établissements
recevant du public les rp n'est pas été
planifié en son temps ça remonte à plus
de 15 ans quand même c'est à dire de ne
pas avoir aidé certains certaines
professions médicales à changer de lieu
à les accepter notamment dans les
nouveaux bâtiments vous avez pu vous
avez accepté de faire construire n'est
pas compliqué de réserver un des lots au
rez-de-chaussée pour pouvoir accueillir
des médecins des infirmiers et autres et
je pense que des médecins plaisir est de
son parti à neuf qui sont partis au
klaxon parti dans dans les villages
environnants même jeudi n'offense pas
méchant c'est pas péjoratif au regard de
plaisir noël arrive à attirer des gens
que de plaisirs n'arrive pas à retenir
donc ils doivent être certainement très
doux et donc la problématique vous me
parlez de de désir médicale aujourd'hui
ben yahya un plan il ya un plan marshall
à faire un plaisir ce qu'on est en train
de dire oui tout le monde est logé à la
même enseigne nous sommes pas loger tous
à la même enseigne à des villes qui
arrivent à s'en sortir mieux et je vais
donner pour exemple montini qu
effectivement pas une vie qui on va dire
gouverner par par la gauche pour
connaître des fois ce qui est bien fait
ils ont réussi à mettre en place un
centre médical puis qu'est ce que vous
entendez par plan marshall s'est
véritablement accès l'aller comment
dirais-je les deux les la volonté de la
ville les la finance de la ville tous
les moyens de la ville pour pouvoir
mettre en place une vraie densification
de du secteur médical à plaisir vous
savez très bien le nombre de médecins
qui resta plaisir médecin généraliste
vous avez vu comme moi les dernières
études
on est vraiment vous dites on est on est
en bas de bas de peloton oui je crois
qu'il reste quatre médecins généralistes
sur la ville c'est quand même pitoyable
on est trente deux mille habitants
c'est normal en après les derniers
chiffres de la rs
des chiffres qui datent de 2010 est donc
ils sont pas encore tout à fait à jour
on était à 14 médecins à à plaisir je
précise juste avant de population
vieillissante un ton oui pour ça que je
vous dis aujourd'hui quatre pense que
même si ce journal je précise juste de
poursuivre ce débat je n'ai pas précisé
qu'il ya aussi un centre hospitalier un
plaisir qui est spécialisée sur la santé
mentale la gériatrie et aussi le médico
social
annie joël prix ou assignés vous
souhaitez je reprends aussi vos propos à
mettre tout en place tous les moyens en
place pour faire revenir
elle est médecin à plaisir vous évoquez
aussi par exemple c'est évoquer on vous
donnera la parole à madame coleman ce
berger dans un instant l'idée d'une
maison médicale maison de santé le
plaisir de santé oui je voulais revenir
et j'en passe je rebondis sur les les
propos de jamal niati effectivement on
aurait pu éviter ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
dans ce paysage médical et social de la
ville à peu près quatre ans il ya eu des
lanceurs d'alerté avec les pharmaciens
les médecins de plaisir qui sont venus
vous voir et vous ne savez pas écouté en
tout cas pas à ce moment là est un peu
trop tard donc effectivement on est
coincé avec beaucoup étaient dans des
copropriétés coincé avec ce set normes
handicap et ce qui est absolument
extraordinaire
enfin incroyable c'est que quand vous
regardez plaisir et que vous gardez où
sont partis les médecins généralistes
ils sont limitrophes à plaisir
effectivement nov les clés etc
et il garde cette patientèle plaisir
oise c'est dire que c'est complètement
incongru c'est un paradoxe
nous avons des plaisirs oies qui sont
obligés de passer la frontière de
plaisir je peux m'exprimer de cette
façon là pour aller se faire soigner
donc le plus intelligent avant d'aller
chercher des médecins ailleurs c'est
déjà de proposer aux médecins qui sont
juste à la porte de plaisir de revenir
chez nous et pour ça il faut instaurer
effectivement une maison de santé mais
aussi la possibilité parce que qu'est ce
qui se passe avec les généralistes
souvent il ya d'autres facteurs
conjoncturels mais ils ont aussi ce
problème de dettes trop ils ont une
charge beaucoup plus importante en fin
de administrative dont il faut les
décharger tout simplement de cette
charge et les municipalités peuvent
prendre en charge justement ces frais là
donc déjà ça serait un atout de pouvoir
les faire venir son plaisir
et puis nous avons encore une fois
université de saint quentin qui n'est
pas très loin ici nous organisons
développons ces résidences d'étudiants
et bien nous aurons également des
internes qui pourront intégrer ces
maisons là patrick jeanteur vous fixé un
objectif c'est d'attirer 10 médecins
d'ici 2026 à plaisir comment y parvenir
comment on attire à nouveau ses médecins
écoutez déjà je vous ai ramené une
petite liste
nous sommes à 6 équivalents temps-plein
médecin non mais c'est important de le
dire aujourd'hui rattachée à amélie donc
à la sécurité sociale réellement actifs
et cette fiche elle m'a été faite par
les médecins plaisir donc je vous laisse
vous mais je là je peux la communauté
fait qu'elles ne pourront pas l'avoir
c'est important parce que nous devrions
droit de sciences si on se réfère à la
moyenne en région parisienne nous
devrions être quasiment à une vingtaine
de médecins
ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont disparu oui
il y en a moins globalement en france
mais y en a au tour nous devrions en
avoir plus nous n'avons pas fait ce
qu'il fallait et nous avons attiré
l'attention à plusieurs reprises donc
c'est quand même dommage
alors nous nous engageons de notre côté
à ce que la ville en tant que tel
investissent sur une maison médicale
nous nous engageons à re faire revenir
effectivement un certain nombre de
médecins en leur apportant le service
associé pour leur permettre de
s'installer pour leur faciliter la vie
et pour leur permettre surtout de
soigner principalement en se chargeant
du secrétariat de la compta du ménage
d'internet et c'est dire voilà vous avez
un certain nombre de mètres carrés dans
une maison pluridisciplinaire de huit à
dix médecins et praticiens qui puisse
venir s'installer et nous sommes en
contact avec un certain nombre de
médecins depuis plusieurs mois qu'ils
sont prêts à venir déjà quatre qui sont
prêts à contractualiser pour venir sur
la ville nous travaillons avec des
médecins et des pharmaciens de la ville
pour monter ce dossier
donc il est important nous sommes prêts
aussi à salarier les médecins c'est un
dossier très important qui se fait pas
n'importe comment qui se fait en
partenariat avec les médecins avec les
praticiens parce que vienne nous dire ce
qu'il faut faire
il ya des médecins aujourd'hui qu'ils
s'arrêtent y compris des moments médecin
qui s'arrêtent quelques années mais qui
souhaitent revenir par exemple à mi
temps et qui demande un salariat nous
allons nous engager sur seul salariat
pour leur permettre de revenir
nous allons travailler aussi sur des
cabines de téléconsultation pour
permettre aux personnes âgées aux
personnes handicapées d'avoir
effectivement une approche un service à
proximité de chez eux chez le pharmacien
en lien avec les médecins de secteur par
exemple et enfin nous travaillerons sur
un centre de premiers secours en lien
avec des chirurgiens et de la médecine
de ville tout ça c'est déjà en ordre de
marche c'est à dire que dans quelques
semaines à partir du moment où nous
viendrons en responsabilité de la ville
de temps de parole nous irons
effectivement de l'avant le dossier est
prêt joséphine coleman verger quelques
éléments de réponse sur ce qu'on a pu
entendre et aussi dire que vous
souhaitez vous faciliter l'accès aux
soins des plaisirs roi il ya un projet
de maison sont épurées professionnels
notamment les plusieurs projets nous
avons plusieurs projets donc je vais
être dans le concret pour vous dire que
la maison de santé dont nous allons ici
est déjà prévu depuis un moment avec le
département le département prend en
charge complètement cette maison
médicale avec trois années
d'accompagnement de fonctionnement au
niveau de tout ce qui est administratif
et le terrain est déjà prévue à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital et ça c'est une
chose qui est déjà en route depuis
longtemps après ce que j'entends de la
part de monsieur jean therme étonne un
peu parce que nous avons mis en place
beaucoup de choses au niveau de
l'hôpital puisque vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure le fait que jeter au conseil de
surveillance
et bien sûr on n'est pas resté les bras
balants le l'hôpital nous met à
disposition des locaux actuellement qui
sont des locaux qui vont accueillir un
médecin généraliste qui sort justement
de l'université de saint quentin
même si on en trouve très peu et que à
la grêle autour d'eux c'est au tour de
josé pas interrompu que jamais et autour
de ce médecin et bien il ya d'autres
praticiens de la ville de plaisir qui
depuis deux années travail pour
accompagner justement cette maison
médicale qui va être construite et en
attendant avoir des locaux au sein de
l'hôpital
pour ce qui est de ce que vous évoquez
monsieur inter concernant ce chirurgien
urgentiste que je connais parfaitement
bien c'est avec moi qu'il travaillait
pas avec vous il travaille actuellement
avec l'hôpital de monsieur girard le
directeur pour ne pas le nommer
ils se sont rencontrés ils ont vu les
locaux est actuellement effectivement il
va y avoir un centre d'accueil pour la
population pour justement les orienter
sur des problèmes d'urgence ou d'urgence
qui pourrait y avoir puisque comme vous
le savez nous avons un scanner
nous avons aussi annie et rennes à
l'hôpital tout ça est et en est en lien
véritablement et des actions concrètes
que nous sommes déjà en train de faire
et qui sont acquittés et conventionné
donc je veux bien qu'on fasse un procès
d'intention ici autour de la table comme
quoi je n'ai rien fait mais c'est faux
d'autres choses que je voudrais vous
dire très rapidement c'est que la
réunion avec les pharmaciens et les
médecins c'est moi qui lui organisait
c'est pas à eux qu'il en demandait c'est
moi on les a rencontrés deux fois et on
semble on a essayé de trouver des
solutions quand on a voulu mettre en
place une maison médicale comme à
montigny comme vous avez dit monsieur
dati effectivement ils ont eu beaucoup
de chance je dirais de médecins en place
ça il a fallu huit ans pour la mettre en
place je le connais très bien de sujets
et bien aucun médecin de plaisir n'a
souhaité nous accompagner parce qu'il
nous fallait une démarche médicale pour
nous accompagner ça a été très très
difficile
alors on a sûrement loupé quelque chose
je veux bien le croire on n'a
certainement pas pris à bras le corps
les problématiques des lieux qui étaient
des lieux à remettre en place
c'est pas à la ville de payer des lieux
privés pour pouvoir mettre en
adaptabilité
c'est pas à la ville de fait on a loupé
des choses mais je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui le concret là il ya
vraiment des vraies solutions qui sont
trouvés de mediative si vous êtes à 7
minutes 34 secondes le temps de parole
les autres candidats aux alentours de 9
ou 10 minutes sont sur le principe oui
vous parliez de sur le principe vous
faites vous faites aujourd'hui mais ça
fait 19 ans que vous êtes aux affaires
moi je suis quand même surpris on dit
gérer c'est prévoir je crois que c'est
ça là je crois qu'il ya eu un loupé donc
sur le principe le côté médical c'est
prégnant aujourd'hui c'est marquant le
centre ludique municipal de santé c'est
quelque chose qui existe monsieur
monsieur l'inter on parlait tout à
l'heure
nous on a eu l'occasion de voir ce qui
se passait dans d'autres communes centre
municipal de santé c'est quoi ce sont
des médecins qui sont salariés de la
commune 1 quelle auquel on fournit un
service administratif leur permettant de
les décharger de toute une partie
administrative sans contrainte
contraignantes pour eux et qui les
empêche de recevoir dès leur patientèle
donc l'objectif c'est aussi de ses
salariés ses salariés ça se fait alors
madame le même humour joints sur un
sujet c'est pas un c'est plusieurs vous
avez tout à fait raison quand je parlais
plan marshall c'était sain c'est
véritablement de remettre véritablement
des centres médicaux dans chaque
quartier
c'est la première des choses après
sociaux sur le principe on parle de
l'hôpital avec je vais être méchant mais
aujourd'hui la problématique de
l'hôpital quel qu'il soit où il se
trouve c'est toujours la même chose
c'est qu'on se retrouve à voir des gens
qui vont aux urgences et qui ne vont pas
se faire soigner donc le la surcharge
dans les hôpitaux
vous êtes en train de déplacer le
problème donc le on va pas résoudre la
situation
non mais ce que je préfère leur dire
parce que sur le principe
bien souvent c'est ce qui c'est on va
dire c'est là la résultante sur la
partie de la partie désert médical oui
il ya des choses à faire mais comme
comme sur plein d'autres choses près
vous parliez du fait que vous aviez vous
étiez aux affaires vous annoncer les
choses j'apprécie c'est comme au conseil
municipal
j'apprends des choses en revenant j'ai
je me demande pourquoi je suis
conseiller municipal je vois pas
l'intérêt d'avoir je dirais pas qu'il
faut avoir la primeur mais encore une
fois un minimum de concertation
donc j'imagine si en tant que conseiller
municipal j'ai pas forcément beaucoup
d'informations le plaisir wade doit être
encore moins bien loti
bon ça c'est un mode de fonctionnement
c'est le vôtre et sur la partie désert
médical pour finir c'est véritablement
le point de le point de deux points
primaire de
de d'un projet aujourd'hui oui
effectivement il faut il faut il faut
mettre en place une organisation qui
soutiennent donc ça veut dire mobiliser
les ressources en interne pas forcément
voir aller rechercher les médecins qui
sont partis à côté parce que quelque
part vous êtes en train de déshabiller
pierre pour habiller paul
mes chers en sorte que faire venir des
gens qui vont s'inscrire dans la durée
dans le temps alors que ce soit des
jeunes des anciens peu importe moi je
vais vous dire une chose
on n'est pas regardant sur le principe
un médecin est un médecin et il faut des
médecins aujourd'hui sur plaisir je
comprends sur le niveau encadrement mais
il faut véritablement remettre ça en
place
il n'y a pas qu'un problème de médecins
mais aussi en prime d'infirmiers
problème de ces beaucoup plus générale
que ça on est en train de l'inité il ya
beaucoup plus mélanie joël prix one et
on fera ensuite un mot de conclusion
n'aura pas le temps d'aborder le thème
de la solidarité mais vous recourez
l'aborder dans votre carte blanche
un mot sur sur pardon sur la
désertification médicale puisque vous
avez une minute environ de retard sur
les autres
oui alors je djamel niati déclare qu
effectivement c'est pas la peine d'aller
chercher les médecins qui sont à côté
je suis désolé mais ils ont une
patientèle quand même plaisir wars
il se déplace à domicile pour visiter
leurs patients donc on peut organiser
quand même une possibilité de temps
partiel ou deux avec effectivement des
maisons qui les accueillent les maisons
santé qui les accueillent donc ça je
pense qu'il n'y a vraiment aucun
problème il suffit d'avoir une volonté
politique ou pouvoir le faire et
diversifiée effectivement également là
les médecins généralistes de toutes
générations
bien évidemment et praticiens infirmiers
tous on les nomme aussi professionnels
de santé oui il faut coordonner organisé
toute une chaîne dans ces maisons pour
accueillir et soigner au mieux les
plaisirs wa évidemment alors comme je
disais on n'a pas le temps
malheureusement d'aborder la dernière
thématique qui est consacrée à la
solidarité mais vous avez encore on va
commencer avec vous d'ailleurs annie
joël ap rio à ce n'est pas ce que vous
avez pris la parole en dernière lors de
du début de débat vous pouvez aborder
cette thématique dans votre conclusion
vous avez environ deux minutes ou tout
simplement dire quelques mots de
conclusion oui alors là c'est la
solidarité effectivement c'est dommage
qu'on puisse pas l'aborder entièrement
puisque ça fait partie de nos axes
principal que l'on ne veut absolument
pas dissocier de l'écologie donc
effectivement qui déjà pour la
solidarité si je peux me permettre
reprendre ce qui a été enlevé à la ville
les éducateurs spécialisés remettre
également le quotient familial pour tous
les tarifs municipaux comme la cantine
mais aussi les séjours les projets
d'école ses terres ce qui se passait
lors de la fin avec la caisse des écoles
voilà donc où et pourquoi augmenter
aussi le coût des tarifs municipaux au
delà de l'inflation monsieur l'inter
vous en avez fait aussi partie de ces
augmentations
donc c'est renforcer le partenariat
entre les travailleurs sociaux et toutes
les coordinations possible les
associations culturelles
voilà donc en fait je vais conclu en
disant il faut recréer du lien entre les
quartiers
géographiquement le lien social est
retrouvé en fait un changement dynamique
une ville moderne qui en a vraiment bien
besoin
joséphine coleman ce berger vous avez
environ une minute dix pour pour
conclure ce débat ou peut être abordée
aussi une thématique
libre à vous écouter quand je fais des
rendez vous et des réunions avec pas mal
de perse
je leur demande qu'est ce qui vous
manque à plaisir est véritablement on
n'a pas des remarques très très négative
moi j'aurais tendance à dire que
l'important aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
bien sûr et je les ai entendus ici
autour de la table une ville nature
puisqu'on en a besoin il faut la
maintenir et la développer il faut
également une ville humaine
on n'a pas parlé de solidarité mais sur
plaisir on a les actions solidaires très
forte véritablement tourné vers la
petite enfance jusqu'aux grands seniors
on est aussi une ville entreprenante et
on le voit d'ailleurs il faut continuer
dans ce sens là et il faut cette
responsabilité moi j'appelle que
j'appelle tout le monde à penser à aux
côtés responsable responsable ça veut
dire la gestion ça veut dire l'écoutent
ça veut dire le partage
dire la construction puisque c'est un
mot à la mode mais c'est un mot que l'on
pratique parce que c'est pas uniquement
quelque chose que l'on dit et que l'on
annonce dans des campagnes 1 on le fait
depuis très très longtemps
patrick jeantet avant de conclure vous
avez environ deux minutes si vous le
souhaitez pour conclure ce débat
oui merci beaucoup un mot sur la ou les
solidarités
il nous apparaît important de renforcer
ou d'aller plus loin sur un certain
nombre dax en particulier le handicap
qui me tient à coeur ça fait 20 ans que
je me bats dans le monde associatif dans
ce domaine là nous avons beaucoup de
choses à faire
nous avons du retard par rapport à
d'autres villes par rapport à certain
nombre de bonnes idées qu'on peut aller
chercher
nous aimerions aller beaucoup beaucoup
plus loin par est un thème particulier
les aidants familiaux
les aidants familiaux que ce soit pour
des enfants handicapés pour des seniors
indépendance c'est un thème formidable
ce sont des personnes formidables auprès
de qui nous nous devons d'apporter un
certain nombre de services un véhicule
pour le transport à la demande
c'est quelque chose qui est fondamental
d'apporter demain nous avons parlé des
navettes interquartiers tout à l'heure
nous mettrons en place effectivement un
véhicule pmr nous irons davantage
renforcer les services de médiation
les services d'accompagnement des
familles des jeunes en général nous
irons effectivement aussi nous attacher
à travailler ensemble j'ai parlé de
démocratie participative tout à l'heure
le conseil des jeunes de conseils de
quartier justement pour animer nos
quartiers les solidarités
c'est aussi une manière de créer du lien
d'animer les quartiers d'animer les
différentes saisons j'ai parlé de
festival des 4 saisons dans nos
différentes propositions et le lien il
est là et pour ne rien oublier le lien
sur les solidarités les aussi vis-à-vis
de nos agents aujourd'hui nous
souhaitons nous proposer une approche
plus vt qualité de vie au travail
certifiante de manière à réellement nous
engager sur des axes visant à permettre
à nos agents qui font un travail
formidable d'être bien accompagné d'être
bien conseillé et de leur permettre une
évolution de carrière satisfaisante
voilà ce sur quoi nous nous engageons
pour
effectivement une ville où il fait bon
vivre en famille dans un milieu nature
et avec toutes les solidarités voulut
jamais nié deux minutes également pour
conclure alors très rapidement sur la
solidarité effectivement c'est le rôle
premier d'une municipalité et notamment
au regard des services publics qui sont
offerts à la population est plus plus de
manière un peu plus un peu plus marquée
par le ccas donc effectivement c'est un
point extrêmement important dans notre
ville la solidarité pourquoi parce qu on
est dans une ville qui est constitué de
plusieurs quartiers voire des anciens
hameaux et il n'y a pas de lien n'y a
pas de lien ne serait ce qu'au niveau
des transports donc déjà c'est une
première barrière
il n'y a pas de lien il ya beaucoup de
ya un tissu associatif très très riche
et très dense mais je pense qu'il faut
encadrer et donner les moyens ces gens
de se parler et de parler au delà du
quartier dans lequel il invite donc
créer véritablement une vraie synergie
après sur sur le principe de 2,2 de
notre liste nous on est ministre qui est
clairement politique en résine
résolument politique
on est dans une approche qui et quand je
dis politique c'est en et relisent
résolument tourné sur un nouveau mode de
gouvernance qui changent véritablement
moi j'ai pas nous on a pas dans notre
dans notre démarche une approche avec
une liste de choses à faire à dire à
proposer et compagnie nous la première
des choses c'est véritablement c'est que
les propositions on va aller on va en
discuter on va les débattre avec les
citoyens parce que sur le principe c'est
tout qu'il faut écouter aujourd'hui on a
vraiment ce que cette problématique mais
maintenant je suis riche d'une
expérience de d'un mandat complet dans
l'ain dans l'opposition plus une fin de
mandat dans l'opposition je me suis
rendu compte d'une chose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la vraie démocratie
on parle de démocratie participative moi
je préfère de démocratie locale c'est
beaucoup plus parlant et c'est beaucoup
plus marquée où les habitants sont
présents dès le début dès le début dans
la démarche et nous notre démarche
allait très simple elle s'articule sur
un triptyque très simple c'est plus
d'égalité réelle inégalité un pas
quelque chose en papa pas de pas de
façade
ensuite l'émancipation des gens il faut
aider les gens à prendre conscience de
ce que c'est qu'une ville comment ce
comment fonctionne une vie et quelles
sont les décisions à prendre par les
deux responsabilités effectivement
madame le maire faisait encore des
demandes la responsabilité c'est ça et
puis après effectivement l'écologie mais
l'écologie est au centre de tout peut
plus vivre aujourd'hui en fermant les
yeux comme il ya 10
20 ans je suis désolé aujourd'hui ça
fait partie c'est la partie centrale
tout doit être raisonnée par rapport à
ces trois points égalité émancipation
écologie le débat touche à sa fin merci
à vous quatre il est temps de parole sa
fiche
jamal dati vous êtes légèrement au
dessus des 12 minutes joséphine coleman
berger 11 minutes 49 patrick j'interroge
minutes 59
annie joël priou hasseni 11 minutes 08
on aura l'occasion bien sûr de
rééquilibrer ces temps de parole d'ici
le 15 mars en vous donnant notamment la
parole dans au sein d'un reportage merci
à vous qui a d'être venu à débat à
retrouver sur notre antenne tv 78 points
comme en replay sur tv 78 points comme
et sur notre application mobile ou en
podcast audio sur radio sensations
yvelines les débats du scrutin des
municipales continue sur tv 78 et
sensations et bim
[Musique]